hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm weird
Brandi we're gonna watch the trailer
today for a Joseph gordon-levitt movie
called the walk I don't know [ __ ] about
this movie me neither so I guess we'll
find out do this the walk must be a must
be an epic walk with a unicorn
now if somebody was high and watching
this that would probably be really fun
just watch this scene because it's feel
like you're on a roller coaster
bodies directed a lot of [ __ ] movies
oh dear I'm feeling nervous for you guys
yeah I feel nervous for him
and giving me anxiety
I heard about that that's right the guy
crossed the hall like this long ass wire
from building the building I remember
that now okay that's cool you're getting
a movie about that what was it about he
just was that just like his thing where
he would just walk around the night he
went from this one building to another
and he just walked on a wire oh I think
it was a wire that's pretty gutsy yeah
no that's [ __ ] crazy that someone did
that in real life Jessica I love it has
weird makeup in this little
weird-looking one thing I love about
Jessica I love it is you could always
tell what he's thinking from his thighs
yes like he doesn't he doesn't need to
speak like he doesn't speak once in that
trailer but you can really feel a lot of
emotion and depth of this guy still
exactly exactly and it's rare the
lighting was pretty cool too it's like
kind of dark
it gave us face some like of what you
can tell is gonna happen it's funny that
we saw this is really scary like we it's
from Robert Zemeckis and we were just
talking about back to the future we were
just talking about back to the future it
was Marty McFly from already McFly for
Halloween and I have the Back to the
Future hat a holographic one from the
second Back to the Future it was fun I
made a hoverboard the idea that was
shooting this in 3d is oh that's because
I was thinking that when they were going
at the building I was starting to get
like chills yeah I was getting anxiety
I'm like yeah it's one of things already
have to start talking because it's so
like yeah you're like you get these
nerves going on yes I think seeing that
in 3d and especially an IMAX then that's
gonna be cool that would be really
exciting you feel like you're really
there if they should be with IMAX
cameras like the actual cameras for IMAX
then that would be tricky because then
it would really feel like you're in it
Joseph gordon-levitt I always feel like
I'm hearing about him in some new movie
like every month there's there's a lot
of movies did you see a little bit did I
say it wrong food isn't it love II love
it
I always said it as lavet I'm pretty
sure it's love it
I I always say things wrong what is a
girl say when she has Joseph
gordon-levitt's penis in her mouth what
Joseph Gordon loved it
Sandra Bullock really no she's like 78
years old I was gonna say that's quite
an age different here's she's like 30 or
something but in Hollywood here she's
like 69 or something yeah she sounds
good she still looks amazing I've seen
some recent pictures of her hi she does
have a single wrinkle though and that
does bother me now Robert Zemeckis I
think he's a fantastic directed some of
its greatest films of our whole [ __ ]
movie history
yeah so it's a seem like hop into this
is pretty neat it's a good teaser I
would like to see exactly how they're
gonna tell the story like does it just
take place during the whole walk or is
it like you really see this guy's
backstory like that's what I'm really
interested in seeing next I hope the
next trailer shows up yeah I think
that's one thing maybe um something
negative about the trailer it doesn't
really at least to me it doesn't really
tell you what it's about
I hadn't heard of the true story based
on this so I thought it was just a guy
committing suicide no it did look like
that
yeah I thought it was just gonna kill
himself and just end his whole [ __ ] show
life I know it sounds weird but I really
like the mood lighting because it gives
it that dark feeling yeah I do hope that
they bring another trailer out so you
can it tells you more but it's about cuz
it didn't really grab my interest that
much I was just kind of confused yeah
fair enough but everyone's different for
what they look for in a trailer so
that's just me personally anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects and Brandi
has a channel too you should check that
shiznit out mm-hmm let's move related in
a lot of its own ways I found her
through a multi-channel network that we
are both part of all full screen looking
great guys yeah I want to go to VidCon
fullscreen
Rafael Torres hey Ryan love your videos
and Sally I was right if I could get a
shout out I was also wondering if maybe
we could see more of the girls interact
with each other for example Veronica and
Sally never seen them together a video
would be interesting to see this guy
just wants to jerk off yeah I mean he
might as well just go watch porn yeah I
mean it's very obvious you just want to
see two girls interact with each other
yeah which is hot you could just google
porn and there's porn of everything rule
34 for every TV show that's out there
apparently there's porn for it yeah you
got born I'm calm read to calm to be
calm xvideos calm you born calm right -
very serenity does he look like
okay oh yeah dude you start masturbating
and literally the thought of Veronica
and Sally I support this Veronica is my
girlfriend and Sally is one of my best
friends but if you want to think about
them together by all means go down there
yourself and do it get a lot of lotion
because look you look really young and
your hormones are probably raging like
crazy or you just want to hump
everything you see so you know I support
that you know hump everything you see
and but yeah you need to get a lot of
lotion probably home ready ha ha
and then I'll be like what is it again
somebody's humping me again ball no I'm
just kidding well would he help you
that's fine you just turn this into like
a really dark drama joke that's what I
was going for I want this to be
emotional Brandi you're so weird and I'm
so right about that no yeah that's why
I'm weird Brandi you know my last name's
Ryan right oh oh that's right that's
right Ryan right he's right about
everything